build it draw it play it vsauce this is
your home for some of the coolest
creations from everyday people this is
bdp
build it
richard burkett builds intricate clock
sculptures out of old machine parts and
other found objects he doesn't see
obsolete machines as junk but as objects
with the potential for a new life so he
dismantles and repurposes them into his
one-of-a-kind fantasy clocks nick jensen
makes life-size halo weaponry out of
lego he's made a whole arsenal of these
things including the m45 tactical
shotgun from halo reach which features a
working trigger pump loadable lego
shotgun shells and shell ejection system
building all kinds of amazing mechanical
sculptures is david kramer one such
creation is the calculator orrery a
mechanical model of the universe
represented by rotating vintage
calculators check out his channel for a
ton of other awesome creations harmless
creatures is a dublin-based duo that
created reimagined costumes for the
wizard of oz the lion is made out of vhs
tape
the scarecrow is rows and rows of hay
and the tin man is made from hand
shredded cardstock
trot
charlotte man makes densely detailed
wall drawings she uses thick black
water-based marker to create one-to-one
scale drawings turning bland white walls
into impressive and unique murals
portraits don't get much more unique
than this beef jerky mosaic jason masir
made the sasquatch with 80 bags of beef
jerky to celebrate what else but
national beef jerky day and now for the
amazing digital art of dave raposa
finally ron gaia created an awesome
series of video game artwork in the
style of movie posters including skyrim
portal
and dead space
play it
it is off duty time nasa astronaut don
pettit created an electric didgeridoo
from a space station vacuum cleaner and
connected it to a speaker covered in
water to visualize the oscillations
brandon robinson's son a microphone and
some clever editing combined to make
this baby beatbox
combining a love of heavy metal and
engineering tristan sean created several
devices to become a truly industrial
one-man band
finally michael h smith created this
surreal animated video for the song
something better by get people
submit your own bdps as a personal
message here on youtube or share them
with everyone over at facebook.com
vsauce gaming
i can see them
national
so
click here to listen to a brand new
installment of bdp radio music created
and submitted by you guys and as always
thanks for watching
you